IT'S AIN, HIS
FOURTH OVERTIME  WINNER OF THE
SEASON, AND THE GOLDEN KNIGHTS
WIWI IT WAS JUST SO MUCH
FUN TO WATCH.
IHANCES.
DEFLECTED OFF OF DRAISAITL. OUT.
TO THE FAR END.EGHE.
THE PASS WAS BROKEN UP.
TWO-ON-ONE PANTHERS.
VATRANO WITH THATKHUDOBIN.
PERFECTLY OVER
OR THEY WILL CONTINUE WITH
I OVERTIME. BEAUTIFUL FINISH BYH
MANSONOOTING, AND SMITH MAKES A
STOP!OOTING, AND SMITH-ONE.
AND HOW ABOUT DARNELL NURSE.
HAD A CAREER
THE FIVE HOLE OF
LINUS ULLMARK.
PRET
ROUGH SHOT, DEFLECTS HIGH AND
BROKE TH THERE
>> THEY REALIZE IT WAS A BROKEN
STICK.
HERTE WITH BURNS
BURNS FANNED TO GET TO THAT ONE.
HERE DOWN THE WING
WAITS, CUTS INSIDE, SHOOTS AND .
SET TO GO FOR THE SHARKS
HE IS 3 FOR SIX FO
KIND OF GOING BACK TO THE REE AT
SHOOTOUTE ON TO GO BACK HAND
TOP.
AND
NOW, BRENT BURNS HAS SCORED A
BEAUTY O
THE BLOCKER IF YOU WILL.
TALBOT S S
JOHN LEONARD
>> THE ROOKIE WINGER W REI SCOR.
AND TH
BLOWS IT UP AN
CHARLIE McAVOY YIELDS
MATCHUP.  KREJCI.
JACK HUGHES IS VERY
GOOD DEFENSIVELY BUT
THREE ON THREE,
DEFENSIVELY,  I
THOUGHT THAT WAS A
GROUP YOU CAN
DEFEATING McAVOY'S
THEY HAD A GREATLIE COY
IS STILL MOVING IN
THAT DIRECTION WHEN
HE MOVES BACK TO HIS
RIGHT.
>> Jack: STRAIGHT TO T
DEVILS.
THERE ONLY WIN HAS
COPERIOD COME
BACK VICTORIES.
OBVIOUSLY NOT THERE
BEST IN TERMS OF
DEFENSIVE COVERAGE AS
WE TAKE A LOOK AT TICKE
ZONE.
ROBERTSON HAS S ON.: AND. R.
AND  WE HAVE YET TO SEE THE
BACKEND AVELLA COLEMAN'S BAG G
BARRELING IN!MOTION AND SPEED G
OFFENSE OF ZONE, POSSESSION OF
THE PUCK.
THE ONE TIMEROUT HI TO PACIORET
THIS.
A GREAT PASS  TO THE FRONT.
KARLSS MAX PACIORETTY LOOKING
EARLIER, THIS WAS  HIGH OVER
THE OPPORTUNITY, KAPRIZOV,
ONLY CHANCE SO FAR THIS SEASON.
IN HIS BUT HE HADN'T..OF
THE POST, OFF OF THE BACK OF
LEHNER .
>> Shane: